I love learning foreign languages in
fact I love it so much that I like to
learn a new language every two years
currently working on my eighth one when
people find out about me they always ask
me how do you do that
what's your secret and to be honest for
many years my answer would be I don't
know
I simply love learning languages people
were never happy with that answer they
wanted to know why they are spending
years trying to learn even one language
never achieving fluency and here I come
learning one language after another they
wanted to know the secret of polyglots
people who speak a lot of languages and
that made me wonder too how do you
actually other polyglots do it what do
we have in common
and what is it that enables us to learn
language is so much faster than other
people I decided to meet other people
like me and find it out the best place
to meet a lot of polyglots is an event
where hundreds of language lovers meet
in one place to practice their languages
there's several of such polyglot events
organized all around the world and so I
decided to go there and ask polyglots
about the methods that they use and so I
met Benny from Ireland who told me that
his method is to start speaking from day
one he learns a few phrases from a
travel phrase book and goes to meet
native speakers and starts having
conversations with them right away
he doesn't mind making even 200 mistakes
a day because that's how he learns based
on the feedback and the best thing is he
doesn't even need to travel a lot today
because you can easily easily have
conversations with native speakers from
the comfort of your living room using
websites I also let Lucas from Brazil
who had a really interesting method to
learn Russian he simply added a hundred
random Russian speakers on skype as
friends and then seriously and then he
opened a chat window with one of them
and wrote hi in Russian and the person
replied hi how are you
Lucas copied this and put it into a text
window with another person and the
person replied I'm fine thank you and
how are you Lucas copied this back to
the first person and in this way he had
to strangers have a conversation
with each other without knowing about it
and soon he would start typing himself
because he had so many of these
conversations that he figured out how
the Russian conversation usually starts
what an ingenious method right and then
I met polyglots who always start by
imitating sounds of the language and
others who always learn the 500 most
frequent words of the language and he
had others who always start by reading
about the grammar if I asked a hundred
different polyglots I heard a hundred
different approaches to learning
languages everybody seems to have a
unique way how they learn a language and
yet we all come to the same result of
speaking several languages fluently and
as I was listening to these polyglots
telling me about their methods it
suddenly dawned on me the one thing we
all have in common is that we simply
found ways how to enjoy the language
learning process all of these polyglots
were talking about language learning as
if it was great fun you should have seen
their faces when they were showing me
their colorful grammar charts and their
carefully handmade flashcards and their
statistics about learning vocabulary
using apps or even how they love to cook
based on recipes in a foreign language
all of them use different methods but
they always make sure it's something
that they personally enjoy I realized
that this is actually how Island
languages myself when I was learning
Spanish I was bored with the text in the
textbook I mean who wants to read about
Xhosa
asking about the directions to the train
station right I wanted to read Harry
Potter instead because that was my
favorite book as a child and I had read
it many times so I got the Spanish
translation of Harry Potter and started
reading and sure enough I didn't
understand almost anything at the
beginning but I kept on reading because
I loved the book and by the end of the
book I was able to follow it almost
without any problems and the same thing
happened when I was learning German I
decided to watch France my favorite
sitcom in German and again at the
beginning it was all just gibberish I
didn't know where one word finished and
another one started but I kept on
watching every day because it's friends
I can watch it in any language I love it
so much and after the second or third
season seriously the dialogue started to
make sense I only realize this after
meeting other polyglots we are no
geniuses and we have no shortcut to
learning languages we simply found ways
how to enjoy the process how to turn
language learning from a boring school
subject into a pleasant activity which
you don't mind doing every day if you
don't like writing words down on paper
you can always type them in an app if
you don't like listening to boring
textbook material a fine interesting
content on YouTube or in podcasts for
any language if you're a more
introverted person and you can imagine
speaking to native speakers right away
you can apply the method of self-talk
you can talk to yourself in the comfort
of your room describing your plans for
the weekend how your day has been or
even take a random picture from your
phone and describe the picture to your
imaginary friend this is how polyglots
learn languages and the best news is
it's available to anyone who's willing
to take the learning into their own
hands so meeting other polyglots helped
me realize that it is really crucial to
find enjoyment in the process of
learning languages but also that joy in
itself is not enough if you want to
achieve fluency in a foreign language
you'll also need to apply three more
principles first of all you'll need
effective methods if you try to memorize
a list of words for a test tomorrow the
words will be stored in your short-term
memory and you'll forget them after a
few days if you however want to keep
words long-term you need to revise them
in the course of a few days repeatedly
using the so called spaced repetition
you can use apps which are based on the
system such as Enki or memorize or you
can write lists of words in a notebook
using the gold-laced method which is
also very popular with many polyglots if
you're not sure which methods are
effective and what is available out
there just check out polyglots youtube
channels and websites and get
inspiration from them if it works for
them it will most probably work for you
too the third principle to follow is to
create a system in your learning we're
all very busy and no one really has time
to learn a language today but we can
create that time if we just plan a bit
ahead
can you wake up 15 minutes earlier than
you normally do that would be the
perfect time to revise some vocabulary
can you listen to your podcast on your
way to work while driving well that
would be great to get some listening
experience there are so many things we
can do without even planning that extra
time such as listening to podcasts on
our way to work or doing our household
chores the important thing is to create
a plan in the learning I will practice
speaking every Tuesday and Thursday with
a friend for 20 minutes I will listen to
a youtube video while having breakfast
if you create a system in your learning
you don't need to find that extra time
because it will become a part of your
everyday life and finally if you want to
learn a language fluently you need also
a bit of patience it's not possible to
learn a language within two months and
it's definitely possible to make a
visible improvement in two months if you
learn in small chunks every day in a way
to enjoy and there is nothing that
motivates us more than our own success I
vividly remember the moment when I
understood the first joke in German when
watching France I was so happy and
motivated and I just kept on watching
that day two more episodes and as I kept
watching I had more and more of those
moments of understanding these little
victories and step-by-step I got to a
level where I could use the language
freely and fluently to express anything
and this is a wonderful feeling I can't
get enough of that feeling and that's
why I learn a language every two years
so this is the whole polyglot secret
find effective methods which you can use
systematically over the period of some
time in a way which you enjoy and this
is how polyglot learn languages within
months not years now some of you may be
thinking that's all very nice to enjoy
language learning but isn't the real
secret that you poly gloss are just
super talented and most of us aren't
well there's one thing I haven't told
you about Benny and Lucas Benny had 11
years of Irish Gaelic and five years of
German at school couldn't speak them at
all
when graduating up to the age of 21 he
thought he didn't have
the language gene and he could not speak
another language then he started to look
for his way of learning languages which
was speaking to native speakers and
getting feedback from them and today
many can easily have a conversation in
ten languages Lukas tried to learn
English at school for ten years it was
one of the worst students in class his
friends even made fun of him gave him a
Russian textbook as a joke because they
thought he would never learn that
language or any language and then Lukas
started to experiment with methods
looking for his own way to learn for
example by having Skype chat
conversations with strangers and after
just 10 years Lukas is able to speak 11
languages fluently does that sound like
a miracle well I see such miracles every
single day as the language mentor I help
people own languages by themselves and I
see this every day people struggled with
language learning for five 10 even 20
years and then they suddenly take their
learning into their own hands start
using materials which they enjoy more
effective methods or they start tracking
their learning so that they can
appreciate their feet their own progress
and that's when suddenly they magically
find the language talent that they were
missing all their lives so if you've
also tried to learn a language and you
gave up thinking it's too difficult or
you don't have the language talent give
it another try
maybe you're also just one enjoyable
method away from learning that language
fluently
maybe you're just one method away from
becoming a polyglot thank you
[Applause]
[Music]